i can't do that for a full minute hi
guys so today i will be showing you how
to make three unique desserts using only
four ingredients chocolate eggs sugar
and cream cheese all the recipes will be
available on taste.co if you want to try
them out for yourself and finally if
you're one of those people that never
seems to have the right ingredients try
the what's in your kitchen feature on
the tasty app plug in up to three
ingredients and you'll see all the
recipes you can make with them let's
make some desserts
[Music]
we're starting things off nice and easy
with the two ingredient chocolate cake
so i have in front of me some semi-sweet
chocolate chips that i'm actually just
going to microwave for about a minute
i can't do that for a full minute boom
i'm just gonna mix this all together get
it nice and incorporated once that's all
set you can put it aside before i
proceed i have to get my eggs ready i
actually need to separate my yolks from
my whites so i'm gonna crack all four of
these into a bowl reach in scoop the
yolk out slip it back and forth between
my fingers until the white comes off
and plop her in and just repeat with the
remaining eggs put my yolks aside using
my handy dandy immersion blender we're
just going to beat the whites until they
form soft peaks
pull that out we've got nice soft loose
peaks i'm just going to put these aside
and move on to the next step my
chocolate has had a moment to cool which
means i'm ready to start adding my yolks
back one by one so we're just going to
plop them in
and mix
and as you stir this is going to start
to thicken up a lot that's totally fine
that's what's supposed to happen
oh yeah
another one
oh this is a fight
come on we're almost there i believe in
you and short last one
and that is what your chocolate needs to
look like for the time being so i have a
large bowl here to which i'm going to
add my chocolate i need to add back my
egg whites but i can't do it all at once
i need to incorporate it about a third
of the time and i just need to fold it
in i don't want to beat all the air that
i've developed in my whites out because
then my cake won't have any rise and as
you can see even with this first third
my chocolate is starting to loosen up a
lot of course scrape down the edges to
make sure every little bit is in there
and add second third
and finally my last and third be patient
don't rush yourself it's gonna take a
little bit of time so as you can see my
whites and chocolate are combined into
this nice dare i say luscious chocolate
combination i have a greased parchment
lined cake pan here into which i'm going
to pour my chocolate
oh yeah and just to make things nice i'm
going to smooth it out to the sides make
sure the whole thing cooks evenly
so my two ingredient cake is finally
cool i'm really excited to see how this
turned out to cut myself a little slice
but just to make it stand out nicely
i've got a little bit of powdered sugar
over the top let's see how this turned
out
now remember this is a two ingredient
chocolate cake so this isn't exactly
what you're used to to me it's almost
like a chocolate tart or a chocolate
brownie it's soft but it's a little bit
chewy but it's super super rich for two
ingredients this is awesome this exceeds
all of my expectations
we are on to the second recipe chocolate
mousse so we're going to take a lot of
the learnings from that first recipe and
kind of expand a little bit here so in
front of me you may notice i have a pot
with a towel in it and this is because
i'm going to use it as a quasi double
boiler and that's to keep my bowl off
indirect heat so i'm going to start by
placing my chocolate in the hot water
and we're just going to stir until the
chocolate melts which should be about
three to five minutes it's handy to have
a towel with you just so that you don't
burn yourself on the edge of that bowl
and if you can see that that right there
it's nice
melted
chocolate give that a final stir take it
off the heat we're going to take my egg
whites and place it in the mixture along
with a tablespoon of sugar i'm just
going to constantly stir this until the
temperature reaches 140 degrees
fahrenheit and you don't want to let
these get too hot you're not trying to
cook your eggs all the way through we're
not making scrambled eggs here we are at
103. 104. we need 140 137. we're three
degrees away 39
and 40. so i'm just going to kill the
heat and immediately take the bowl off
now that my eggs are off the heat we're
going to do like we did in the last
recipe and we're going to eat these soft
beets
[Music]
and that looks like a soft peak to me
[Music]
our burner returns i'm going to add my
four egg yolks just a little bit of
water and sugar and i'm just going to
beat this mixture until it's nice and
foamy and the temperature reaches about
160 to 170 degrees
and that looks like 160 to me kill my
heat
and like before just pull my eggs off
the heat and set them aside i'm going to
add back my melted chocolate to it it's
going to take a minute to combine the
residual heat's going to help it melt
down keep stirring keep going be patient
on this step so as you can see after a
little bit of stirring it starts to come
together it's really really nice and
glossy there's almost like a sheen to it
look at that
nice and glossy and combined so i'm
gonna add just a little scoop of the egg
white and slowly
mix that in i'm just gonna add the
remainder of my egg white as you can see
here it's really really nicely
incorporated so the texture of this
looks great i'm actually just going to
transfer it to a little measuring cup
pour that in there so my final step at
this point i'm just going to pour my
mousse mixture into two little ramekins
look at that
try and be as even as we can this one
needs a little bit of help come on clean
that off because presentation is
everything this is going to bother me
unless i even it out we're almost done
you just need a little bit more patience
these need to sit in the fridge for
about an hour or overnight and i'll see
you when they're done
my chocolate mousse is nice and set
which means the only thing i have left
to do is try it at this point
nice and
creamy
oh my god i love chocolate mousse it is
one of my all-time favorite desserts
this is great it is so light and fluffy
and creamy and chocolatey it's like
eating a chocolate cloud it's two of my
recipes down but stick around i have a
chocolate cheesecake recipe you want to
see
[Music]
this last recipe is our most
show-stopping recipe a four ingredient
cheesecake so to start much like the
first recipe we're gonna have to
microwave some chocolate my chocolate is
done but i just want to add it to a
larger bowl it's going to make sure
everything is incorporated to that i'm
going to add my room temperature cream
cheese finally my sugar and get your
arms ready we're going to whisk this all
together
[Music]
yeah
look at that that is some thick
chocolate right there it's time to add
the egg yolk and mix
and this is where the texture's really
going to start to change it's going to
get that nice glossy sheen to it
oh yeah check around the sides there
make sure we got
everything off so as you can see our
chocolate is nice and it falls and
ribbons and it's got a beautiful sheen
to it we can set this aside we're going
to grab our egg whites i've got my
chocolate mixture back i'm going to fold
in my egg white mixture a little bit at
a time
i'm just going to gradually incorporate
that
the last of my egg white
and this has some serious volume to it
i'm doing my best not to knock the air
out as much as possible so i'm just
gradually folding it in today has been
an arm workout definitely on the source
side and there you are that nice liquid
gold right there is our cheesecake
batter set that aside so i have my
greased cake ban here i am just going to
pour my batter into it oh yeah look at
that you really can't ask for
anything better that be our cheesecake
so you're probably wondering why is this
pan in a bigger pan and that is because
in order to help the cheesecake cook to
keep it moist we need to add boiling
water to the outside so i have my kettle
here that i just had boiling i'm going
to add enough water to be halfway up the
side like that so now that that is done
all we have to do is throw it in the
oven for about 35 to 40 minutes and then
let it chill overnight and we've got
ourselves a cheesecake so my cheesecake
has been setting overnight it looks
great i want to dig in because this
looks fantastic it looks really
beautiful for four ingredients
cut
oh wow
and then a little maraschino cherry
just for a little bit of presentation
just to make it look nice let's give it
a taste
wow
it's so
airy and so well balanced i feel like
cheesecakes can be a little bit too tart
or a little bit too dense but this is
nice and fluffy and nice and delicate
this slaps this is great and there you
have it three desserts using only four
ingredients we had the super simple yet
surprisingly rich two ingredient
chocolate cake we had my personal
favorite the fluffy chocolate mousse and
we rounded things out with the decadent
show-stopping four ingredient cheesecake
let me know what you think of the
recipes in the comments below they will
all be available on tasty.com of course
if you have any suggestions for what
you'd want to see also let me know in
the comments below remember to check out
the what's in my kitchen feature now on
the tasty app and until next time have a
good one
oh yes
[Music]
you